all right and we are both live one is
under the weather but we both will have
the last word on these Luna shooters
what's going on Humana I feel it man
well if you can't tell by my voice I've
been fighting through some junk oh this
is one of those times like everybody in
this area seems to be getting sick right
now quite a few people at work so it's
just one of those you're like you work
with people enough like in close
quarters it's gonna happen so my voice
took the front of it it seems like at
this point so I do apologize I'll be let
incognito get some points out there and
he's got some good opinions today if
they're out for the world so you gonna
let him get those out there yeah but you
guys can still hear me so and we are
having a happy this man is powering
through for y'all right now let me
explain this is what we do like there
were there were less videos on the
channel this week but the podcast got to
happen absolutely Russia to the chat
people rolling in shouted he bought his
chef vagabond oh I see you back say John
good morning good morning and um my chat
Ravager one of the first cats live par-5
what's going on yes it's Friday we made
it and we're gonna talk these games man
but uh I know you've been under the
weather but what have you gotten a
chance to play for me a little bit of
crimson crimson day is just basically
enough to get my basically just enough
to get good but you had to be better
like one day potentially perfect mr. de
la poles in the building sir how you
doing good to see you could see you in
the loo to shoot around I like that
that's good oh yeah for me I literally
touch like I went to Shaq's got a few
things done but I've been so busy this
week I really haven't got a chance and a
little concern because I gotta get this
stuff done because it's only here for
the week and we know what's launching a
conclusion of said podcast it might be
like King girlie by the way it's left
just like that I'm worried I'm worried
because it's like I know myself and the
minute I launch anthem crimson days
might be a rap and I don't know how to
handle this problem because this is a
time thing I need to get these bigs so I
will tell you the best way to do it and
for all of those of you who need to know
talk there's daily bounties they're
worth like 15 they're usually not that
bad and then there's a night fault duo
so find one other person
I'll throw like a singe and a heavy
weight on there knock out a nightfall
the night falls were 75 of the currency
and you need 25 more to get the bow and
everything else is cosmetic so it's
optional so that's that's literally all
I did I did at nightfall with my brother
and then like we did two bounties and I
was done and it was like you know kind
of done so we'll get to we'll get to our
thoughts on that in a little bit but
yeah that's my recommendation know that
I might take your advice man it's gonna
be school it's gonna be tough man to man
dizzy what's going on buddy how you
doing friend but uh yeah man we got we
got a lot to talk about but uh what kind
of convinced because we know a box is
hurrying today the cheetah is under the
weather so we want the stress off is
anita's over there by the fire light so
it'll be my telepathic thoughts to the
Cheetahs ears are gonna get a fair
amount of Cognito this morning and you
know just like you dizzy I'm feeling not
a hundred percent or at least my voice I
don't feel but actually that bad it was
Wednesday when I was probably at my
worst
yesterday was okay feel a little better
just the voice at this point is the last
piece but feeling okay so it's like I'm
in here with you just in spirit mostly
it seems like every sheet is here in
spirit that's why we got so well we got
it we got a little table action man we
got a little time action so we can we
got a candy shell coated swop yesterday
and yeah crimson days have been live
that's the big thing this week and I
know you didn't get a chance to play
much but you knew it was coming you kind
of know what's involved mm-hmm what do
you think yeah right now it's more so um
I will get into this table I think they
did a bad job of explaining the mechanic
this year
because I didn't know it I may be excuse
me baby if it was my fault that I missed
it but it's not until this problem will
get into it that I understood more
mechanics of a 2v2 crucible so I was in
there you know with a Rando we was
getting it on Shaq's was saying his
sweet nothings on during the match and
fun but um I mean look it's crimson days
I actually think it's probably one of
the better iterations of it but it's
just a small time event you know you're
tied into Valentine's Day you have your
fun you get your things and at least
this time they have a reward tied to it
so I do like that I always like when
these are rewards are there and I mean
so it's good and then um l-boogie what's
good what's good good morning good
morning um yeah so you know it's one of
those things that you get into get out
you know and I just got to get it done
but I do actually like the mechanic when
you go to get the confectionery arts you
do all that stuff well you know what did
you think you know for your limited time
that you have been in it you know I mean
basically that it is short term I kind
of wish it wasn't just a week because I
mean they do have an exclusive like
reward to it
so it would be nice if they gave even
just a second week I mean they don't
have that much else going on we now know
the date will chill get to of what comes
next and I mean they're worried about
overlap and with iron banner I guess but
I mean just to leave the quest out there
or something like I don't know it would
be some people you never know if you're
gonna travel for a week and when you put
an exclusive piece out there of gear
it's like yeah I know it's not that big
a deal but it's literally like it's the
only solar bow from normal activities
yeah we do last wish solar boughs still
off the table yeah right yeah absolutely
that's my only thing is just give it a
little longer to simmer I there started
a week earlier which wouldn't have done
they had nothing going on last week
absolutely nothing and so there's no
reason to not start it last week even if
you do want to squeeze iron banner in
and give us another week to work on it
there's no reason not to so that's my
only thought was it's small it's simple
it's all cosmetics yeah except the bow
and just to give people that one more
win three weeks they're in thunderlord
over a three request and then they gave
us even longer after that before the
thing was going to go away it was there
for
mm-hmm quite a while yes and then this
one's like literally seven days we out
late it's just a little too quick it
feels yeah you know in and out like
wham-bam and I'm out of here so yeah I
think I think what it is is to be honest
this is my thinking of there this is my
reasoning I guess she'll put myself in
their head is to thought processes
there's more so like hey let's be honest
crimson days was never all well received
event so I think they're like alright
let's just throw this out and then
marketing it ties into the Valentine's
Day week you know they get that free
little extra push with that and then
they're like okay we get out of here
then what kind of gauge feedback but
maybe I think this is one of those
things maybe they just didn't have
enough content necessarily to extend it
two weeks when even though the realities
they probably should have brought up so
I'm with you yeah I would love another
week to just get in there and get stuff
done and you know it looks like they're
gonna be once we get into the twirl
there gonna be there's a reason why it's
not a second week we'll get it yeah
that's my thought on it you know overall
yeah I mean it's pretty lackluster I
mean the tower always looks kind of cool
you have the petals everywhere so did
you play much of the crimson day sexual
like crucible playlist oh yeah that's
how I played exclusively when I really
went to shag sort of tower so the rose
petals on the ground sort of got the
little bounties and I head up the
crucible now again I which is messing
with that mechanic you know doing stuff
and I didn't get the chance to do any of
the PvE stuff either knife all kind of
stuff which gives you more confectionery
hearts but I did do the 2v2 crucible and
yeah you know couple maps in couple
matches just got to finish that out yeah
what you feel the mechanic or just would
you why did the how did the two's feel
were they with people you knew work um
it was ring and oh sorry about my dogs
by the way I salute to Saladin some
wolves um oh yeah there's somebody
outside there could be somebody like in
my like street and she's like uh no
that's that's mine my doors shut
a minute that's though hey man the
wolves a howl and they like to control
flavor I love it but uh yeah now play I
play Miranda but the mechanic itself has
been fun you know I'm saying IIIi like
it you know
but again I'm biased towards crucible so
it's like I like that I actually like
the first crimson days with the teeth
with the - me too
you know I'm saying it's just something
different you know and let's get into
the twelve because I definitely want to
talk about said mechanic into it but uh
yeah man so we got that and then uh you
know they say loves in the air shacks
handing out those rewards you see the
the cool tower looking and then um you
know obviously the power bow as a reward
so are we gonna get into what's
underneath that there's a slightly big
deal coming so we'll get to the crimson
days in a little bit but they kind of
did this a little out of order for
whatever reason yes but this is a big
topic of the day morning scream I'm sure
you're gonna have something to say off
for all of you guys we got we got some
final news on trials so I'm gonna leave
this on screen I'm gonna let cognate
okay so yeah let's see let's let's open
this can of worms floor sewers yes this
was definitely a talking point then I
saw whether or not reviewing it so let's
get into it so trials ever since trials
benign went on hiatus back in season
four many of you have been asking when
it will come back and how it will be
evolving we still don't have a timetable
for when it may return but we do want to
give you an update on our current
thinking about trials here is the team
to fill you in
yesterday dev tea as a longtime destiny
players no trials of Osiris was released
in May of 2015 as the original high
stakes weekend PvP event trials had an
amazing impact on our game and our
community it was the pinnacle venue for
players to show off their best skills
strategies and gear the 3v3 elimination
mode combined with the car system
created the coveted reward of earning
the trip to the lighthouse with the
introduction of trials and ining destiny
- we made a few changes to the former
which never really hit the same
we were unhappy with its role in the
ecosystem the new activity wasn't
achieving the goal of bringing the
community together every weekend both
destiny and the online PvP scene have
evolved since 2015 so we don't believe
that bringing back the 2015 version of
trials of Osiris would accomplish what
our goals are to date until we have a
solid prototype for integral PvP Indian
activity trials is staying on
indefinitely on highest indefinitely and
will not return over the course of the
next few seasons when we have those new
plans ready we'll be sure to share them
with you oh boy let me know when you're
ready for me to go
oh man it's it's all yours you got this
thing started this is yours for the day
I'll chime in later but you you go to
town sir let me get ready cuz man this
this hurt this hurt y'all um I gotta get
to it all right first off you know how I
feel about trials trials of Osiris is
not only lore wise one of the coolest
things in d1 Gear was one of the coolest
things in d1 mode my PvP mode wise one
of the coolest modes 3v3 elimination in
in d1 trials was a phenomena they said
released in May of 2015 this trials had
an amazing impact that's what they say
it was pinnacle you know this was this
was the height and let's not forget
trials during d ones launched I believe
it launched in the house of wolves DLC
am i right Ibanez I believe I believe it
was I mean House of wolves do I remember
the initial reaction to house of wolves
was negative once it was found out there
was no raid attached remember cuz
everybody thought we were gonna get a
falling rain back then and we ended up
getting trials we played it and the
community went wow the streaming
community went wow this the carries
everything associated went wild so for
them to say
you know that they they didn't like the
mold they didn't feel like it was the
new version right they're saying the new
trials of the nine didn't achieve that
right they're unhappy what I'm cool with
that
I'm fine with that we all know trials
benign was not a success we all know you
know the fourth person didn't
necessarily work as well they took away
kind of the boons they took away
basically some core elements and the
elimination aspect and they initially
just made it almost like a 454 pvp skin
to be honest right well and it was the
meta at the time - and right you're 1 d2
was yeah I mean it was just bad in many
so many ways I mean you had the weapons
lost the weren't feeling quite right
everything stuck in the slot I mean it
wasn't even they took this they took
that away before this meta this whole
gun that you know slot everything showed
up so I mean even even tried it with
that absolutely but here's my major
issue and I got a rant on this and this
is what has me very upset when they make
a statement that both destiny and the
online PvP scene has evolved since 2015
so we don't believe that bringing back
the 2015 version of trials or Osiris
would accomplish our goals are you nuts
like that that to me is tone-deaf I'm
sorry I gotta go in that was the
pinnacle mode what is wrong with
bringing back 3v3 elimination I don't
understand if your community loves it it
was proven to be a streaming success why
are they resistant to bringing it back I
just don't get that why can't we have
the exact iteration that we want you
know I mean that is it because you want
to force the fourth player you know I'm
saying like I just struggle with that II
and I'm trying to give them the benefit
of the doubt I I didn't say remember
trials we didn't get any updates for
mumps I could have been going crazy
I said i'ma let it let it cook you know
mean you had that internal bet you know
will it come back you know so far no
disclosure I've already lost the bet now
again so far over it so like you're
getting drinks upon drinks at Guardian
con now you guys have put aside
they say it is on hiatus and they said
it will not return over the course of
few seasons plural season few not a few
we have two seasons left in this year
that's as few few is more than two
unless you're just gonna be like okay
about it but as to a few is three like
three to four yeah I was like that's all
that's like we're not seeing it in d2
ever but my thing is this I would have
been cool with that if they say hey a
few seasons we're gonna get it right but
to me it's a slap in the face of the
trials community to say that the 2015
version of trials was not is not is not
something that they could see will be
successful right now I don't get that
man I really don't understand the logic
behind that so you know I'm upset I'll
be shot to fall out plays you know he
had a tweet that was literally my
feelings exactly which was like yo I'm
in my feelings fall I was like hey I'm
heavily in my feelings right now you
know that it is a it's an ear indeed you
know what that's a good equipment to me
II that's the equivalent of saying I
know vault of glass was the most amazing
thing we did but we will not bring back
raids until we have something that is to
the current standard of what we feel
raised like that's what trials is for
the PvP community bro again I'm trying
to be balanced here I really am I'm
trying not to be the just pylon bungee
kind of guy you know I understand
development I understand things you know
you want to put things in the right
place but you already had the formula
you had you had the sauce man you got
the sauce why are we going away from the
sauce alright I'm a brief have a let you
jump in it's upsetting man it's really
upsetting to me and and I just I don't
understand why they are so resistant to
3v3
elimination bring back Osiris
no one sock crazy
chick you know I'm saying let's get it
let's get it right now let's do it uh uh
continue go go I'm here dine with the
one sock crazy chick coming judgement
who is this chick we don't want her get
her out of here this is not a goal you
know I understand they wanted to bring
the nine involved and you know I get
that you know people very curious about
the nine but you can't tell you put a
gun to anybody's head
what's more cooler the 900 Cyrus and
wearing that Egyptian gear and looking
like our moon rocks and looking like
King Tut in Tower Ted let's put a poll
up I challenged Bungie to put a poll up
and say trials of the nine that Lord
gear set up versus trials of Osiris it's
a landslide it would be a landslide so
why do they spit in the face of the
community with this decision ego go for
it man D what's up baby what's up K I
mean we got a lot of things out there
and catching some of it from the chat
and pieces here so dizzy is basically
saying I mean do you think they're
throwing they're talking about the
evolution of the you know PvP scene in
like just the overall world right now
I'm sorry
hey dude okay bring it back to earth we
gotta have a chat now attack a chat what
evolution damn it what has no but if
they're talking about like siege for
like what that's like you know that kind
of tactical level you've got battle
Royales out there everywhere it's like I
don't know what they're you know maybe
they're looking at all the options out
there so yeah but you've also gotta go
okay so put yourself in d1 reef you had
brother Vance in the reef as your vendor
yeah so is he gonna be in the tower now
is the thing you don't need that already
in the Merc okay but I mean if solutions
eh
I'm gonna give you solution right now
mercury is useless it's the Rotunda that
nobody goes to well I know right so
let's let's make mercury relevant let's
make mercury great again let's get our
Red Hat's oh my god you know let's put
them put him put them the
use right now he's a clown he's a joke
character we can still go back there do
the Osiris story now is universally
carceral songs known as a failure right
let's regroup let's revive it revamp it
you know what I'm saying
oh wow Thank You rat the wall wow thank
you so much brother with the $10 super
chat I hope y'all having a good day I'm
playing the new Metro on PC and it looks
beautiful salute you put a good day
brother you have it a good I'm not
having a good day right now but you have
it a good bit I'm living through you and
yes Metro looks fantastic but I'm sorry
I'm just gonna finish that point it's
just that they got two assets man you
know say it's like what what what really
unless you're telling me you're trying
to catch a wave you're trying to do
battle royal you know I'm saying it
dizzy oh my god he's out of the next day
the race is gonna be trials of Benedict
19 I know vasilich Cyrus was University
before absolutely all I'm saying is
let's let's regurgitated use that so
that that and that planted on that map
on that director now has that wait again
you know I'm saying that that's all and
it's just salute the same refrain he
says d1 fraud wasn't broke they should
just give it back to the people I just
don't understand the logic man hell no I
mean honestly like for putting 3v3 back
in I really don't know I mean as you
said like Vance is there just use him in
the same way yeah if you want to go to
mercury to get your car and it's just
like going to the reef to get your card
you have your three VIII's now my
curiosity is you've got the guns now are
getting closer back to where they were
in d1 it's probably the best they've
been for meta and the way things feel on
the other side you've got how do the
maps feel in d2 compared to d1 yeah a
couple carries over you have the one on
Mercury itself which is you know pretty
much just a reskin but outside of that
one that I know was one of the trials
maps how do you think some of these maps
would play in d2 jimes whole 3v3 of
elimination I'm just curious like you're
the Christian guy yeah no listen you're
accurate as the maps current
least and right there they're suited for
44 for that 4v4 meta which they
initially launched II to it you know Sam
so I get that all you gotta do is make
trials specific Maps right you already
have the lighthouse map that they
brought back right so I mean not the
lighthouse but you I forgot the name it
was it burning trying is that what it
cool I feel like it used to be I forget
the new name but yeah that's it unless
you know they've already got that that
could set it off as the first map for
the week you know I'm saying or whatever
right so if the maps are too big I'm
winching you've got all this time you've
got tons of old assets and we know
Bungie is the king of reusing old assets
right did you come back and just say
boom give up put a nice little coat of
paint on it they were already met for
3v3 elimination and there you go you
don't even really have to make any
really new maps so again I'm not really
trying to hear that excuse that they're
saying which is it the PvP sphere has
evolved well let unless but I see that
that just means to me that you're trying
to catch a wave and then I'm getting
nervous because that means you're seeing
either battle royal or you seeing
something else that you think or like
you said Rainbow six siege
well like I don't know what it is that
you see that you're gonna go away from
your own moneymaker
that doesn't that's not smart business
the trials of Osiris is what made you
who you are and let's keep it 100
hunted PvP PvE fans and no disrespect
you eat but when d1 was on its deathbed
and that content dropped before taking
King guess what was keeping Destiny
alive people were painting people to go
to the lighthouse that's how I know
people I'm not going I'm not gonna
disclose their business but I know
certain people is my club or other clans
that would they was so desperate to go
to the longhouse once they found
resources I mean you're not wrong it was
a common thing for people doing carriers
I mean there were people you knew that
was like literally their job on the
weekend
just sad this saddens me man this really
hurt me to my core bro I was just like
I'm willing to give up if I'm willing to
concede they don't want to do Osiris I'm
willing to concede they'll keep trouser
denied I was even willing to see a
little with the PvP 4v4 elimination
right but to sit there and not even
bring the mold back and then you talking
all this in indefinite hiatus you know
that tells me d3 to me that that means
we ain't getting we ain't getting this
this is not this is they are not about
that at all that's what I see there but
that means they're struggling with this
the struggle I mean we're in a new world
a bungie at this point then they don't
have Activision at their back absolutely
they don't have that in a good and a bad
way sadly which could be one of those
times where they're like we have
potentially d3 that we're looking at
figuring out when we're gonna launch we
have a decision to make about what
September will hold if anything and
changing like what destiny has been for
the past five six years to see what are
we gonna launch where do we put our
priorities are we putting it back into
this mode now again I don't know what
the development cycle would be like to
put elimination back in does it feel
like it would be that much no but what
do I know you've got all that stuff out
there and there I mean as we you and I
talked off like we've got you know over
the course of the next few seasons this
line right here says a lot over what is
to come like is September gonna be just
another Annual Pass of some smaller
stuff while the live team kind of keeps
us afloat and going give you some time
to cycle on a couple of these other
games as they're gonna be popular
whatever that's gonna wait for and then
maybe it's 2020 with new consoles and d3
and this giant new launch of something
Bungie wants to make is that the time
when everything comes back in full swing
I mean the only thing like I said when I
hear that kind of stuff yes they don't
have Activision you know behind them
right now and I get that and it also I
think me and you've had this discussion
offline which is um
you know we mainly see different cadence
now we are so conditioned I think you
were the first to bring this we are so
conditioned to that September destiny
release but let's just be honest you
know I'm saying got the kick foot out
deal before guys sold his soul to pay
for the lighthouse oh my god that is
hilarious right now
he literally call someone out that was
in a clan at page but um yeah but like I
think you may be on to something here I
think the the days of us being
conditioned to the traditional release
cycle may have been purely an Activision
thing right so active it may say hey
September this is when it comes out
right and now that they don't have the
news from around their neck once the
season of the redacted is done they may
just say when they say few seasons it's
not gonna return they may say to himself
we're just gonna take our time we're
gonna drop on we're gonna drop and then
maybe one more one and it may not be in
September and we'll get one more piece
of content maybe it's maybe it's at the
top of the uno maybe you know two top of
2020 and then they prepped themselves
for d3 but it just may this is scary
stuff man to me this this is this is
scary stuff I don't know I don't know
man I really wish I had an answer it's
just very confusing me I'm glad that
they got in front of it I will say that
I'm glad that a statement was me because
you know my blood was boiling every 12
why are we not talking about it what's
going on we remember we would look at
the development map right and we would
look at every bullet point for every
season of The Drifter of the redacted
and we'd look for anything that would
say trials or new PvP activity hoping it
would be trials and that wasn't there so
then for them to finally get him out of
it and say hey not happening you know
this is what you think man I mean I
don't know this is very conservative
I mean said friend said in chat show
that it's like pushing
new game right now just doesn't feel
like the right move that's what I'm
thinking like annual pass for the next
year and maintain t2 with what they've
got seeing what they can kind of evolve
their formula with everything they've
got
maybe people burned out the beginning of
destiny and burned destiny to year one
did the same thing like burn a lot of
people it's like d3 how many times can
you how many times can you launch and
mess it up
absolutely absolutely that's kind of one
sorry I guess I guess the thing the key
thing I it just feels to me that they
feel 3v3 elimination is is whack like
like they like they feel like it's a
it's a it's taboo to do that I just I
don't know I mean that one I don't know
it's like it's a different mode and
that's probably one thing more people we
had I feel like we have so many
different modes in d1 where it was you
had Rumble you had elimination you had
you know rift and supremacy and like all
those little like buttons in the
crucible and I feel like now we just
have modifications of like control and
clash and that's like really all we've
got for PvP I don't know if they wanted
to try things couldn't put them in can't
find the right feel and they get stuck
in this 44 and they don't have these
options now because the way the game
might be designed I know they can do
twos whether it's the bounces I mean
somebody was like yeah it's like if
nothing else you've got things like oh I
don't know blade bars that are just
gonna break the whole world I mean so
supers are different things are there
it's like what is so the way the whole
systems are made down maybe they have
tried these threes and maybe it just
doesn't feel the same now I mean that's
that's speculation and who knows so it's
like what all of us like to see it and
this is one it's like couldn't you do
like crucible Labs would be perfect to
try us crap out it's read my mind you
just read my mind like me and that would
be your perfect place to be like you
guys want this look we're gonna go
crucible we're gonna do threes for
elimination but just what the maps
because and you can and this is one of
those points where I feel like we wish
we could talk to the to the destiny
crucible team or whoever's in charge of
this and be like hey we're thinking
about doing this and everybody in the
world will be like please just put it in
and let us try and you
hate it will tell you if it doesn't feel
right you're gonna know it but if it
does work then why not let us see that's
my point why don't you trust your
community this is to me this is a lack
of trust they are trying to do something
to fly too ambitious you don't need to
do anything ambitious you don't make
sure to do he says they brought in the
pvp mode that was terrible was that pvp
was it break down what was the name of
that one right through or something like
that
break 4 yeah at least they tried it you
know they attract you you know you know
hey what's up punch it you know it's one
of those things that um you know you've
got all these great streamers and
resource you got a guy like a fallout
plays you got a guy like I asked across
right you you've got a community that
you could fly in the same way you
treated the PvE content the raid and all
that you can fly these guys in the top
trials guys have them go in there put
that thing through the paces and you may
be right it may be part of it maybe the
map sighs I'm willing to concede that
but you meaning to tell me that you
can't just use specific maps you know a
smaller map or create them to engage it
it just automatic a slap on it so far
this is very strange to me I would love
to have the opportunity to sit in front
of the sandbox team and really pick
their brains and really I would love the
thought process to why they feel that
the PvP scene has evolved past 3v3
elimination you know they're like you
know I made your phone shut up Oh acting
crazy but oh yeah it's just this is this
is this is a tough one this was a blow
this did this the type of stuff that I'm
like y'all keep this up be careful with
me right now but I'm very upset
a bit my feelings it's just an
interesting time because new games are
out Bungie was like yeah we're getting
to that next but it's just it's a time
the
they have they have tools like crucible
abs you have a community that's like as
gonna give you all the feedback you need
I mean if you put it out and be like hey
we want to try this you guys have been
requesting it we have crucible labs it's
not gonna affect that much but if you
guys want to see how this thing feels
now since at least the weapons are there
and I wish they would just say that and
just be like we're gonna try this we
it's like we have a lot of feedback from
you saying you want to see it and maybe
after this post this is something they
would see photos like me and if if they
could just use crucible labs for like
the one thing that everybody is dying
for just if nothing else let all of us
see that yeah it doesn't have that magic
back and then at least we would know as
well like something happened like d1 to
d2 whether all the changes there that
time to kills the supers the stats the
builds all of those things I mean you
don't even have some Sun Sun singers
self-rising anymore which was that was
the thing I mean that whole self res
like gave trials like the wasn't gonna
res I got watch this I gotta watch this
- oh so fun I mean those were the times
of like if you're gonna do that you had
to watch that Orban you had to sit there
and man if they sell for us they could
mess you up fast so it means I'm gonna
say one point I'm a crush their whole
old nonsense narrative if they run away
you know how I know this is still BS and
I'm worried now because remember d2
Vennela right we're going through the
launch it was bad right it was PvP was
bad everybody was running away there was
- it was the old weapons system right
everybody was like this is terrible we
don't like PvP no more remember that
right and then there was one flash point
we did back then do a flash point right
it was a tribe we did now never forget
it he and they said for one week only
we're bringing back mayhem and if you
remember that week how much fun the
community had in that matter with the
primary weapons do you remember like oh
my god PvP feels great right now
I could play mayhem all day
same thing with trials literally forced
it and gave it to us as a sample for
what we can say go ahead just see what
it is give us it for one week and I
swear the community will go crazy
they'll go crazy it's me
whoa breathe who'sa breathe breathe
yeah we got him we got him worked up
over there gotta get him with a glass of
cold water
there's no excuse there's no excuse
they've done this before they brought a
mo back in a terrible meta and the
community loved it bring trials back in
this meta let us decide whether or not
it's evolved since 2015 don't take away
off our love man PvP guys we need this
bro
we need this that's the only day
everything else you guys have been doing
has been fantastic
forsaken fantastic and then I'm saying
we got your creative freedom now just
give us this bungee give us this man
that we really the PvP guys are dying we
don't have in game content every other
mode has an even people there's a strong
a gambits community right now damn it is
lit gap is about to get its own dlc
dying out here we got no true meaning a
war we got yeah competitive the only
thing you gave us was really you know
the Lunas howl and competitive scene I
respect that balls really going in their
planned glory like that you know it's
just sad I can't get myself to do it I
can't like and that's part of the
problem with that is the fact that I
know most half the people on the list
have the damn gun so I'm gonna
disadvantage anyway yeah but I'm done
yeah seek free I do need a cold shower
stressful or I'm sorry I'm sorry about
it it's just it's a sad day for me I'm
the pvp guy and I'm dying inside you're
not you're not wrong that's one of those
four for a lot of people out there who
were either people who a lot of it was
just people enjoyed watching trials like
the twitch community like that for the
the things that would happen the skilled
like plays that people would do I mean
but you've also got like how does that
now Snipes are getting better as well
I've seen more people doing that so I
mean it's getting to a point where it's
a thing
but a miss types were a huge thing in
trials for all of all of those pieces
and it's like I'm with so many changes
they made in d2 I feel like I mean
people like Cosmo people like Dylann
those guys were playing before they even
I mean they were playing trials before
they worked at Bungie all I want to say
is this and in my rant I will never
forget walking into the tower and you
walk past a guardian and he had that
full Egyptian guard he had the doctrine
of passing on his back your Z and you
like yo you hit that inspect button like
what is that I didn't women in destiny
was Pisces 3 or whatever one and they
had the drooling ornaments member he was
looking like a pharaoh
you were looking like guard in the top
that made me a spy I never stepped foot
in competitive PvP in d1 I stayed away
until that I said oh what is that
I got that from Trump what Strauss I got
to get over there and every week it was
like religion man and then the cool
thing that they did was they added that
system that for the people who weren't
to try hard so the people who couldn't
get to the lighthouse
you had your bounty that just play the
mold right get wins get whatever you
know you had your boat and you can still
come off with some non adapt care and
some non adapt but it was so cool man it
was the coolest thing I'll never forget
when you got that that sense of
accomplishment when you hit the
lighthouse Pro I still had let me tell
you I still have on my xbox DVR my only
lighthouse run that's how emotional
people were when they finally did it it
was it was crazy you couldn't tell me
that Egyptian thing was it was it was it
was some special man whoa everybody
feels back look at that warlock man has
he got all these options so you got like
these were the big three
it was it that was a crazy set of armor
it looked cool you have the the Egyptian
god you got Anubis over there like the
Sun right here for the hunter they were
all just they were Coulee a doctrine of
passing had it's like place of being and
that's honestly like that magic oh I
don't know if d2 can do it and like it's
one of those I mean what do you it's a
hard thing in their world you I mean you
know they're not deaf obviously they're
putting this post out there they're
listening they have had they had to have
tried variations of this to see how it
feels how it goes and I they either they
know something that it's just it feels
like trash or just the card system
doesn't have quite the same luster I
don't know what it is they know things
that we don't and we have the statistics
to prove no I'm not saying it wouldn't
be popular I'm saying it may not it may
not be the same thing that you remember
from d1 if they try and put it in d2
whether it's the size of the maps
whether it's the supers whether it's the
builds whether it's the stats whether it
is all those things together buying it
may have proved that you bring the mold
back and it's intact state it can still
be fun oh maybe it was mayhem is so
broken right now are you kidding me
yeah it's me no it's not mayhem not
funny not since blade barrage was
introduced as mayhem fun that's one
thing what's super you know there but
that's one but yeah like they haven't
touched it yet have they yeah I got you
on tape you gotta pull up the records
I'm just saying like if I would go into
mayhem I would have a lot of fun either
throwing hammers or other things like
that blade brush and it seems like if
anybody's gonna run a him yeah there are
other things in there and it's fun when
you don't worry but if you run into a
team of like three or four blade brushes
especially if they have shades a gallon
or I told you I had that dude kill me
three times our own is just like what
the hell like we're moments like that
that don't feel right
it's two dollar super chat oh my god
battle run no battle royale damn it
don't you know I think that would be
interesting though not saying I want
that instead
trials I just think I just think about a
bigger group I think that's one thing
either King's been saying it now that
stuff is just I would like to actually
see like a bigger group like we've had
sixes and stuff but I mean like twelves
or I don't know just a bigger a bigger
smash together of Destiny's PvP would be
hilarious between and just I don't know
you can get maps with the size of like
first light or Skywatch or things like
that we're so much bigger with vehicles
all that stuff going on in d2 I think
would be crazy you know again not buying
their whole thing but you know we'll see
what the plan is but yeah you keep this
up yeah I mean there's other stuff
coming in bit and that's a decision that
maybe they do this and they know these
big things are gonna launching it at
some point every game does dwindle off a
little bit and then do they wait til the
stuffed windows and it's like you know
if anthem comes up now a division 2
comes out now all this stuff is gonna be
coming those are gonna have some cycle
and then when those are finally towards
the end of their first year they can--it
apron off they're really not an issue
they come back as the big loser looter
shooter in 2020 brand new consoles brand
new destiny I mean in this that might be
whether they save it for that or not
that might be where they have their
focus right now you know I don't know
but that's all I got ran over you guys
that's it nothing else you sure you're
good let me go I'll go again you know
how I get thank you guys for laughing at
my back you know it's very motion I do
this topic would bring it out of me but
know what else we got man they got
ironing boards so yeah we got iron
banner coming back next week which I
guess is the other reason why crimson
days it's just a week long looks like we
got a grenade launcher and I don't know
if that's a scout rifle the sniper rifle
only knows longer is that the scout of
the pulse I really don't know looks like
the pulse I believe that is claws of the
wolf if that is that's a good gun get
some good rolls on there so grenade
launcher yeah don't really care don't
really love too many grenade launchers
but yeah that pull that cause the wolf
actually gonna have some pretty good
rolls I still need my blast furnace
though like this week I should be
grinding it out but
I'm about to change games that I'm gonna
play here in about oh eight minutes yeah
iron banner this is the final one for
season of the forge so if you're looking
for armor pieces if you're looking for
any good
anything else starts next week and it
will be a week long and then that seems
like it's going to be our downtime which
we'll get to we do have quite so here's
your crimson days you wanted to talk
about that so here's your crimson day as
mechanics so this is out of order guys
and or drove them back to crimson if you
won't talk about the mechanic of crimson
days what do you think I mean this is
your time to jump in I know we got it
got it out of order but we're here oh
that's fine oh yeah I didn't know first
of all shout to the chat long they
saying that my sounds a little off just
let me know if it's still the same way I
don't know you seem yeah you seemed
mostly okay at least in my ears
okay yeah cuz a my chat also let me know
how my sound is just want to make sure
everything's good with that but um yeah
while I'm talking
um yes since that I didn't know about
these mechanics where you obviously the
player account and then we have you know
players jumping solo if they choose we
know about that but then we they break
down reunited that buff which is a
special buff that increases the recharge
rate of Guardian abilities for teammates
who stick close together and then they
have one that says are falling apart
falling apart is the debuff that grants
enemy teammates waypoints to your
locations when you and your teammate
drift too far apart and I have sound
that you know say all shout out put is
you to check you said that my mic sounds
fine he's just that I'm all in my
feelings thank you that's definitely
true yeah you're so up Ellen your
feelings that Mike can take it so that
that falling apart did notice that
because uh we playing who's I was with a
Rando and it can't good to see you
brother I love you too man good stuff
we'll see you Sunday and the Lord's Day
you already know um yeah so beard pretty
much I remember seeing that way I was
playing against the opposing team and
they tried to separate real far and the
map crown of stitch snitched their
locations out I never seen that before
in crimson it was interesting yeah and
then the last one vengeance vengeance is
triggered when a player's teammate is
defeated in combat for a short time this
of
Playa is going to significantly increase
ability regeneration and receives a
small portion of their health back so I
just felt it would have been cool for
them to kind of save this before last
last love cuz I've never really
understood those mechanics and um I
actually thought those are pretty cool
like they they're really encouraging you
to stay close I remember they had
similar stuff but I don't remember and
past crimson days I just don't remember
it being this detailed and they
definitely didn't have um the the one
that says falling apart where it shows
you waypoints I definitely don't
remember that from past crimes I feel
like I actually do Tristan did they have
a visual representation on the radar
like okay I don't know if there's the
radar or the Waypoint or something but I
feel like if you got split up it was
like really noticeable if you did so but
yeah I mean the 2v2 kind of has its own
feel I mean you'll see a whole lot like
if you play with one warlock you got
that little um like rift can't tell you
like the few games that actually did
play how many people were just chillin
on the roof together like if they were
like down around or something they just
said they're waiting like come here what
are you gonna do like I mean I actually
saw that quite a bit
like what kind of a huge cuz you're
supposed to state stated it you may as
well be harder to kill so they would
cuddle it up in the wrist you know it's
yeah they're very snugly but yeah it was
like I don't know I played with my
brother and like whether my skill based
matchmaking him like somewhere like I'm
in the okay arrange my brother says he's
not great in PvP and then he jumps with
me and we usually seem to do okay so I
don't think he gives himself enough
credit but we did we did okay we had
some fun if we like you know stepped up
on the heavy ammo got that one you know
I could get like three or four of them
with good old thunderlord putting in
some work yeah that falling apart as
soon as they split like they would be
trying to flank but me it makes flanking
nearly impossible because you're like I
know exactly where you're at so it
really kind of changes the feels to it
so I don't know I mean it was ok was
kind of fun doing to just with my
brother for a little bit
Sean stone you shine it's the wolf
but oh and all I mean it's it's okay I
wish they would do more stuff like this
though where you have like the
reunited buff or things like that just
random things like that they can throw
they have all these as we've said before
crucible Labs is very underutilized this
is just a test of like you know if
you're in proximity with guardians you
get you know a buff or you know if you
go be a lone wolf or something maybe you
go invisible like if you're far enough
away from your team you actually drop
off the radar so you could flank for a
change I don't know it'd just be it'd be
interesting for them to mess with
mechanics and I feel like they never
like really step outside of their box
much and just it'd be nice to see them
do that a lot more it would be cool for
them to do a little bit more that stuff
but you can step out of their box into
three be threes and see how that goes
you know I don't know it's it's one of
those things that could happen you're
like really we got that we got better
you know you know pretty much cool
little Iron Man a week coming right back
around you know for the short little
trim and feel like that was like maybe a
week or two off then we're right back to
it again yeah right back to it man I
don't know do you care about iron banner
anymore I remember I'm a PvP guy so if I
guess he you see how you say said that
and again to bring it back to trials I
have nothing so this is everything
that's how easier you're like PvP as the
cops go by oh hey they're about to call
the police on Bungie for getting rid of
trials oh my god but the big in that all
jokes aside like the thing is as a PvP
you know I would say main but as one of
my favorite modes
you know you do kind of get excited for
a banner because it's like you don't
really have any you know differential
mode so I mean it is just control you
get that in quick play and it's all
money capture I know the capture
mechanic is different but that's
literally all you get like besides the
fact that like you're 650 your max level
the balinese really don't do you much
it's like yeah you'll get a few rolls in
here I mean the armor
ormer does actually look kind of cool
are you that he why's a hardcore pvp guy
why you like it you like it because the
control point mechanic is different when
that what's the terminology when when
it's locked is a turn they use I can't
remember the three it's really fun man
because what happens is you know you can
dominate you can push people off you can
do comebacks so you got that aspect and
then all four gear wise at least I could
speak for the warlocks that um the iron
banner gear tends to run high from
resilience so you know you can spec
certain bills you know certain things
they come with a little cool little
roles the weapons this year haven't been
that great but this week I would play
because I like causing a wolf it's a
great gun it's just not stable so you
get some little stability roles or so
some mods on it
it's a it's a very good pulse in the
energy slot you know cuz most of the
dominant pulse is right now in the
current meta alright like you know
obviously your favorite you know you go
figure and when you can't leave home it
out you know yeah you know you got your
bygones and and so on and so forth the
chattering bones but if you really look
at it the energy slot doesn't have a lot
of strong pulses so this this is cool
you know I would I would play for that I
play for my little thing and I know get
in get out get your kitchen bounties you
don't need to the power level per se but
um as a PvP card was starving man this
is the kind of stuff we look forward to
I hate regular you know I mean that's
just I was honestly surely asking cuz
for me it's like yeah it's like I mean
but it it's not anything that much of a
departure from what we're used to so it
just doesn't seem like it's that big of
a deal I mean the bounties they'll serve
me too much I mean my hunter I could
probably use some of those honestly if I
do play but I mean with other games out
there and stuff like that we got coming
up you're really gonna go jump back into
iron Manor just next week that's the
point you make that is valid and because
of no trials and nothing different you
know these are the kind of things during
the downtime that wouldn't push me now -
okay and thumbs out you know okay
division to bait is out you know hey you
know apex legends and all this other hot
stuff is out so it's just like you know
it is it is what it is you know and it
just
that's why I'm so sad because I know the
reality of no trials and as much as
people who don't play it what happens is
investment and engagement goes away and
you really lose your community and if
these two other two games which we're
about to talk about it really go strong
you know I just don't want this
community to fall off that's literally
what I want you know so we'll see we'll
see they've got time you know to try to
fix it and do it you know this community
of falling apart you want to make sure
we're reunited we got to be reunited
this court you're gonna come back with a
vengeance oh yeah Darrell right I think
we should move on jeez factors none
ultimate high right now blowing past
that she would definitely cheese it
right there l-boogie what do you mean is
it Dow what do you explain L boogie
explain community we'll go it's my
opinion it's just my opinion PvP is a
backbone mm-hmm but that's all I got you
know well we got some issues that will
be fixed at the start of season The
Drifter which is good the black art
Mikey mold for one player is getting
fixed dreaming City chests I'm saving
the accelerator and just quite a few
fixes that people have been waiting on
to my knowledge a lot of them are gonna
get resolved they don't have it they
don't have a list of things that are
unresolved so this is good as well we'll
have to see what comes when the patch
notes are full and we finally know the
date after we get past the videos yeah
see like I do solo flawless shattered
throne and somebody does solo flawless
no hood shattered throne and of course
there's a way to make me look bad but
the final piece drop the big knowledge
of the week so news about destiny is
random and light this week winter
visited in the Pacific Northwest and
blanketed all its splendor with an
immovable object a mutt Lotus no bungee
has been at work they've been doing
stuff from home we don't tend to
maintain the irresistible force of a
fleet of PLAs we don't tend to maintain
the irresistible force of a fleet of
plow trucks
one weekend of the year that looks like
this so early in the week we hunkered
down with our laptops and way to feel
the whole thing to blow over that
doesn't mean that our progress has been
interrupted we've been working from our
homes to prepare for next season and we
are back in the office now as the white
fluffy powder devolves into a brownish
mush which is true if you've been around
snow it goes from white to garbage
really quick season of The Drifter will
arrive on March 5th with some exciting
evolutions for your guardian lifestyle
that's some sentence 2d hook just
construct here in a second we'll begin
that conversation soon tweet and then
you'll have a few weeks to reap all the
rewards from season of the forge have
you got the new bow hope so cuz you only
have like three days to get it just look
nothing out there yeah mine have a great
time in crimson doubles they did their
little Bungie bounty and stuff like that
season of The Drifter we have our
official date of March 5th what do you
think we basically called it so yeah
we're basically called I mean you know
it's one of hold on one sec hey to keep
talking trials with l-boogie I can't
type fast enough and I have to address
her comment basically she's saying that
um you know that season hibernation mode
because they have no direction right now
they've had a major break up and now
they have to figure out what they want
to do and oh by the way they have less
manpower and resources all of that is
true how about you what I am saying that
that's not my point my point is the
terminology they use in this table is
that the mode itself is not something
that is appealing to them to bring back
I have a problem with that you can tell
me hey we don't have enough time we want
to get it in the right place we don't
have manpower but they literally are
attacking the mode as if it's not hot
and they want to do something else and
that I got a major problem with because
of the fact that that was their key mode
that had the most engagement that
everybody loves and the whole community
wants so why smack your community in the
face by saying you're not gonna bring
that mode back like I mean just that
specific variation
I can understand say hey we're gonna
cook it we're gonna make it better fine
but to attack three weekly elimination
I'm not with that that to me is
something else back to your point with
our March 5th we
predicted it you know with the drifter
what's he will say yo we gotta see how
this thing is gonna play out I am
curious about the lore you know I'm
saying like how this is gonna play I'm
curious about thorn you know say like
what's gonna happen with dad and maybe
even rose you know obviously drift it
wasn't too happy after the last word
quest or whatever so um you know we'll
see I'm curious March 5th is interesting
it'll be anthem will be already out um
before about what is it one week two
weeks about two weeks before division
two divisions a month from today price
it's 20 something so you know we get in
we get out you know we see what's up I'm
curious I'm gonna give it a shot you
know I'm gonna keep expectations low
you know it's just their phrasing is
interesting they said new evolutions to
your Guardian lifestyle like that's a
weird weird term yeah personally just
because it says right here evolutions
for your Guardian lifestyle I don't know
what that means cuz you've got you've
got gambit private matches and new maps
you're like okay that's not really
change anything crazy power increase
fine vanity new lords Ironman Earl or
there's an exotic quest for everyone
there's an exotic quest for the annual
past people so at least that both people
get one this time spring event which we
haven't had a spring event before so I'm
not sure what that's gonna be you got
your Joker's wild weapons and gear the
new gambit experience
xur bounties by the way cannot forget
sir bounties those are actually gonna be
a thing I don't know if they're gonna
matter but the fact that their thing I'm
kind of happy about yeah it's the fact
that they exist now they finally are
like oh yeah is there that dude up in
the tree like give him something to do
you've got Joker's wild which is a
weekly quest I don't know that one's
gonna do some evolution kind of like 801
with her like weekly weekly powerful
frames I guess would be my assumption
but yeah there's no raid no new six
player match made activity there's no
you know they don't know don't they say
Joker's wild weapons in gear but I mean
I don't expect a ton we haven't had a
huge jump of like new
new guns new year 1 editions anything
like that we had it really just like
reskin the basics and then we had the
powerful frames we didn't get that much
really getting the exotic armor new
exotic homer in season forge that's true
yeah
yeah we didn't get any or anything about
that you know I have five weapons which
were basically all fort related mm-hmm
and had no armor man they don't they do
not like their exotic armor they do they
they don't want to put it they don't
want to make it masterworks they don't
want to let us get boards they don't
want to let's get extra stats they don't
want they don't I don't know what is up
like masterwork armor is something that
we've probably hoped for for a long time
and can't touch it again and this is
this is the time to be listening to your
community especially when the
competition is coming and they look good
and it could take time away and
engagement away from your game do what
your community what you to do that's I'm
being nice though they're in transition
I'm being nice well yeah that's what we
get to expect on March 5th so we know
our date
we have no trials apparently I get a
beverage so yes
first rounds on you all right but all
that being said let me go back to where
I was there are other things to discuss
shockingly good anthems little
conviction teaser come out so did you
watch it that's what's up what's our
guy's name what's up guy you okay oh man
Wow let me tell you something man if
this for those who have watched it if
this is the level of storytelling that
I'm gonna be getting if this is the
narrative feel if this is the tone oh
boy
anthems coming oh boy did you think when
you saw it I just was like I was trying
to figure out what was going on and then
I saw some stuff come out from deal
Neill himself basically just kind of
explaining if it felt like a trailer for
a bigger movie which is what I wanted
that I want the whole hour and a half of
whatever this is from but it sounded
like they shot like 20 minutes and
they're like there's a big script we
can't do all that then they had to cut
stuff down so they actually had
apparently he had a lot more that he
wanted to do but they couldn't make the
full his full vision with the budget
they had so he still ended up shooting
like 10 minutes of stuff to like you
know edit it down to like three minutes
so they could use a lot so it was like a
10 page script even just for a little
trailer they made it was really cool I
just want to see like the 20 30 minute
like cinematic amazing like maybe anthem
comes out makes him some I don't know
but I would love to see more of this it
was really cool it was really cool yeah
if you guys have not seen it definitely
check it out it was like aute Studios
which is neo blow camps thing but yeah I
should just look up anthem conviction
you'll find it it's like three minutes
long nothing crazy
um it doesn't like give anything away or
whatever but just like the feel of it
I'd love to see about like I'd love to
see a full you know 2030 or full movie
of this I take 90 minutes I take a full
a full by Flevoland give my like the
budget yeah it's like let Neil Beauchamp
handle anthem find a director for you
know wife to work with on this level of
production I mean the artists like
crushed it on his lore video but still
it would be they'd be crazy but yeah
anthem is literally live right now by
the way guys so as we're recording this
anthem is up servers are gone literally
checking with my brother he jumped out
of my discord he's in another district
ready to play literally right now other
stones shout out to him
I don't know I mean he's just waiting
for me to get done I know he'll play
with me so yeah like anthems live today
so I mean for when we're talking about
other games come in different things to
do and stuff like that this is
this is one of two big ones now
everybody has different opinions about
this I was literally about to jump on
here I was about to hack my way into
your podcast last weekend you would be
oh my god I'm still out there right now
or addict or whatever but yeah I was
like trust me there were there would
have been some words for me and it's not
saying I'll not saying all the stuff
they said was it justified but it's also
it's like you're forgetting about the
way all the other games that we do
already play are the true referencing
the way they work as well so there are
certain things yes do I agree with all
of them no but there are the ones you
just like choosing to rag on it so hard
I later come on
so again but again if you don't find it
fun you're not gonna find it fun I'm not
gonna force you to extra hard and at the
end of the day I still I think you know
this thing has a great foundation and we
still there's still so much stuff we
don't know for me to just disparage it
you know I'm saying and listen I had a
lot of fun you know on PC I had a lot of
fun so you know this thing looked
phenomenal it felt good it played good
you know what variability base which
I've had to learn and um yeah man I am
I'm actually ready for the campaign I
want to know about this naira know oh
why we're doing this
the freelancers the javelins I want to
see you know the antagony I want to see
all that man so I'm excited you know
it's finally here origin premiere access
what we even talked about how they
convoluted messed up that was what it is
yeah I mean there was so full disclosure
on origin the launcher on PC at least
for those of you who had the origin
premiere access there was a date
floating around that it was gonna be
available for at least me in like
central time you would be an hour
forward it's gonna be like 4:30 p.m. on
Thursday on yesterday but forever they
had been saying March 15th March or
February 15 February 15 sever it is like
are we actually getting it early is it
February 15th because it's like or
halfway around the world but I mean
they're based they'd been doing all the
stuff from Canada and stuff so I mean I
was kind of getting my hopes up a little
but I mean some people are saying hey
it's going live and then all of a sudden
it's like no it's really actually
tomorrow so there was like there was a
bad miscommunication
origin and Bioware for the actual live
dates somebody didn't check the copy of
the script that was going out and it
should have definitely been checked but
I was like you'll be fine
sleep actually it probably if nothing
else people are like oh I'm totally
ready because it was gonna be like
Thursday night or it's done Friday you
probably didn't take off your days any
different that's not like it was gonna
be Thursday morning so it was not really
like
I never said it was like actually I'm
not saying it shouldn't have been
checked I'm using of their own game like
that that's a little weird to be because
I can't let that slide like let's see
but this is like the point where you
wonder like how far is this by or trying
to stay away from EA like if they're
this far apart and there's that much of
a disconnect I have hoped that Bioware
is putting their morals and stuff behind
this game not EA is that everybody seems
to hate which for me is hopefully gonna
give them you know better hope of
traveling as well and just like their
transparency and everything has been
great so the miscommunication between
those two if that just means they don't
work with EA as much as like everybody
thinks they are I'm okay with that
I'll just read in and say hey that might
be a good thing because bio is trying to
do it their way I and you actually you
actually predicted I mean I predict you
literally said what my point was did
we're on the same page which is it just
showed that there could be a disconnect
there between like you said EA Empire
were caused by wear themselves have been
ultimately transparent if you follow
them you get a ton of information I get
that it's just funny that EA didn't know
what was going weird like I mean they
even said it they're like when's it
going live there like a just in the
stream I was watching it was either
Wednesday nights or thursday stream or
something when I finally got to the
stream they're like it's gonna be
February 15th Central Time 9:00 a.m. and
it's like all right and then like you
know I checked and things had been
updated at that point I think or they
did it probably pretty quick but either
way it was just like yeah they probably
have all should have been on the same
page in some way somehow like all the
stuff is thy mean they put like Ben
Irving the guy posts on Reddit and one
of those images of like the time it
launches was out there on Reddit so
you're going guys
I mean all of those things but yeah it
is sorry I may have not have said that
but it is for or on PC it is alive if
you have origin premiere access so
that's the early access if you have
origin or what does the EA access Xbox
you get 10 hours yeah yeah so hope those
communities can actually get your touch
on you know that would be honestly I
mean I'm glad I'm on PC but I don't even
know if I could do 10 hours and then
stop for a week it's like I got this new
drug and then cut cold turkey for like
six days you probably could ten hours in
the first day and be like well access
how it works is you you still get the
option to have it early because you do
the ten-hour trial and I believe I was
like it doesn't sound like it everybody
saying they get 10 hours until next week
oh maybe you're right yeah I mean that's
the way it it's I've read it at least I
could be wrong I don't know but yeah I
was like I think it's mostly just
premiere access on PC so us PC players I
will be streaming it and stuff like that
so you guys can check me out there if
you don't want anything spoiled of
course you can now save it for yourself
but the other piece mm-hmm we're gonna
talk about oh like believe me once we
actually get our hands we're not gonna
dive too far in anthem we played the
demos before we talked about it there's
gonna be the real version one thing to
know about anthem
there is the like version that's going
live today so this is what they were
able to get in for February 15th but
there's a patch going for lunch like a
day one patch that will have changes
that will even be different for us next
week so not everything is in this patch
and then things will still be changing
as well so there will still be some
things that are changing I think a lot
of the things are in the 15th but not
everything's in the 15th so just keep
that in mind if you're seeing stuff out
there 15th and 22nd will probably have
some differences too final one we got to
talk about it start where you let me
stop Division two and private beta
happened over the past weekend there is
gonna be an open beta so if you didn't
get a chance to play a private the open
beta will get to the dates on that one
um but I want to get your thoughts I
mean you guys were
shout out to iron Lords podcast for
absolutely just ripping apart Anthony I
was not slits I was about you
like I literally I didn't get a chance
to get most of it alive but I stepped in
and you were finally good fighting oh my
god you couldn't get a word in edgewise
so those guys they just done with it
listen do you know for the people who
didn't list the episode it's just more
so the main thing is the loot drops the
way they're handled in an time and that
they have an issue with as well as you
know addicts issues which is in game
he's a raid guy so being that there's no
convention raised to as we know to this
point you know that's what's literally
you know got him to now but whatever
this game looks great
I'm we getting a day one we don't Exodus
projects we you know we're jumping in
put on yeah as far as the vision man um
got a chance to really um dig deep in it
and um I enjoyed it in a different
manner than I anticipated
meaning that um shot the novela but yeah
I'm not to get into it the thing about
it is it literally I could play it like
a single-player RPG because what I was
doing is you know I was going to my
settlements you know I was I was like
kind of taking doing little tasks for
them to build them up and they would
give me specific rewards and stuff like
that and then what was cool was doing
the control points so they had different
pockets of the cities where these like
this group called the hyenas they were
taking over and it literally feels like
first of all the atmosphere of the game
literally feels like some
post-apocalyptic the city is run by
lawlessness because they're like
everyone's just doing whatever they want
to do you know when you got the groups
and stuff and um I love that feel man it
was really cool so what I liked was the
control point and you know they had an
area I went in there kind of tactical
started to take them down then they
started to get hot and heavy bosses came
in and you have the ability to hold with
the on Xbox the whole ex throw up a
flare and being that already you know
help that settlement and I had a
settlement established that was in the
vicinity they came over it was like four
or five to help me out as a solo player
in the fight I love that mechanic like
it just felt
so cool man like I love it you don't say
so yes I see y'all talking crap in the
chat yes there was some issues I did
have some technical issues at least I
got into the demo
unlike anthems first giant but um yeah
man I like dizzy I get it it's not for
you bro it's bland and boring it's just
not for you I'm having a great time but
um yeah man so basically what happened
is I got those guys in and um you know
we kind of took over the control point
you know loved it and then from there
you kind of establish a little community
with that control point and then they
have they asked for resources and stuff
like that and I want that touched a
little bit of PvP really enjoyed that
you know saying so again it's showing me
that I can play this solo which I didn't
expect
the also thing that I like that they do
which destiny needs to do is if there's
other people on your friends list or in
the world having problems you'll hear
this thing of like agent needs your help
or whatever it was now you can disable
that but the thing I like about it it
kind of it promotes a cooperative thing
so if you help someone you don't say get
back up like you chew you can go into
their world and vice versa
and I like that and I wish destiny had
that like when you're on patrols and
stuff you know it's just a cool thing
you know saying like I'd never think I
would enjoy it that much okay and then I
like how the game as you go through the
campaign it gets you through the dark
zones you then I'm saying it kind of
gets you a feel of how that's gonna go
and then obviously the one bit of end
game that they let you have which I
thought was really cool was that a black
tusk faction that comes in as an endgame
that takes over think of it if you're a
destiny fan think of it like the takin
comes it's like the taking comes on air
on every strike in every part of the map
and now they play different that you
have to handle them different they're
harder you know really cool and we
haven't even seen the radius so again
division is one of those games then if
you didn't like the first one and mind
you I wasn't a fan of the first one I
didn't like the end game you know I'm
saying if you didn't like the first one
or you don't like tactical shooters this
game is not for you
straight up this is not space managed
magic this is none of that you know this
is cover-to-cover base and RPG mechanics
and looking at bills and doing gear sets
if you love that minutia with good team
play this is for you I'm saying if not
hey you got anthem you got you got
destiny this disc is gonna do well
though only for the simple fact that
they've got a lot of different modes in
a lot of different ways to play and I
think that community was very strong
towards the end when a lot of people
stopped playing it that game got better
and better and I think their start
unlike destiny to which regressed at its
launch division brought all the features
that got better at the end of the one at
this launch so you know I think they're
gonna be fun I think they really are
gonna be fun so we'll see they've had
the issues they got the NOx I did the
director put out a tweet you know pretty
much all the issues that were in the UM
the initial beta like there was some
sound drops I know a couple people got
kicked here in there you know the sound
drops what I experienced where the gun
wasn't making you know anything
I get had that the whole time really all
we had at one point console I've only
had it like once or twice honestly but I
heard I had a a long time couple times
and then now the first day they patched
something overnight like 3:00 a.m. and
that was where like my delta errors like
delta 3 like i got that like seven times
the first essay and then like i didn't
really get that maybe maybe once for the
rest of the time i played after that so
it was like that overnight patch did
seem to fix the delt errors which was
good and shout out to both games like
anthem in this like make him pretty
quick switches on getting some things
flowing better after first day hiccups
like it's good that they can actually
make those adaptations like this like
this is stuff we we're not subtly used
to with the world of destiny because
everything seems to take a little bit
longer like if they can do like live
patches overnight update things where
they like literally fix stuff on the fly
that's actually really really good news
for both of these that they can be
adaptive and change stuff up as they
need to right yeah absolutely shout to
sam refrán and check he says if you're
not the same level as your friends
you'll still join them the game
scales you up to them still earn XP and
keep your loop you know I'm saying yeah
I love that aspect again it's it's
little things minutiae and more it's a
solid gameplay experience I'm not
worried about the division in the lease
it's just one of those things that yeah
they still got some work they have to do
they still have them
you know bugs and technical issues they
gotta fix and they still have to um we
still have to see that in game we have
to see how that that actually is and I
noticed thatone it once it you get over
three players the bosses did get sponger
so I want to know how they handled it
because I felt the time to kill was in a
really good place when I play solos or
what it would do would you know a double
but um Lucy but I know you your
experience wasn't that good I know your
dark tourism was good so tell me about
your experience wasn't that good
so I mean mine was things like I mean
change in levels between a Ledge or
something like that I got hung up for
like 10 seconds and a looping animation
and that's just like that's like deep
down engine code base so I mean that
stuff where you got to wonder like stuff
getting fixed it felt like me like if I
got out of cover or if I wanted to like
me being in cover and then I turn out
like pop out of cover I wasn't felt like
I was glued to cover and it felt more
like on pillars like if I was going back
and forth on something on sometimes like
the cover felt like I was sticky as I
should be but then there were other
times I'd be like on the edge and it was
like hey I want a peek out or I want to
go turn the other way and it's like back
away from the cover like he didn't feel
like I don't know it didn't feel the
same as do you like d1 like I would tell
you there was like one of the best cover
shooters I've ever experienced
absolutely Division one was it was solid
like and something about this one felt
different to me that didn't feel what
yeah I had cover
I had cover issues whether a staining
cover or getting from like there were
times I was working perfect like it was
working as it should felt like Division
one and then there were other times it
just didn't feel quite right to me it
was like whether was trying to go up and
down and said those looping animations
get stuck it was like doorway so I would
be like stuck on or trying to like go
around the corner and I'd be like clunk
I'd have to like step back away go out
and around and make it very deliberate
to like not catch so there were there
were technical glitches like that though
we're messing with me quite a bit which
kind of annoying um and then kind of as
you're saying you're rather gonna really
like this game or you're not and this is
just a personal preference thing too and
I'm not saying I don't I'm probably
gonna pick this thing up and try it out
because yeah I know it was a beta but in
turn it's also how how much you can
enjoy this now when you have like armor
plating on some of these guys instead of
a dude in a in a beanie but you're
shooting with like six thousand bullets
that actually had a better feel and
shout-out to skill up he had a pretty
good break down on this one um that at
least gave it a better feel in your head
like hey dozen bullets into this guy and
not fighting a giant Titan or a giant
you know or six or whatever in anthem
I'm like okay some giant crazy thing
yeah that's probably him take a few more
and this you're still fighting humans
they have a way to finally make it make
sense in people's heads so this money if
they are spongy in your head you're like
okay it kind of makes sense now if I put
a sniper rifle in somebody's heads not
like Ghost Recon where they die it's
still an RPG and that's just one of
those things you gotta decide if you
like or you don't
true that should it and that's again a
feel I mean there are there space magic
there's people on other planets with
like you know Iron Man suits and then
you truly you're still walking around DC
with people if I shoot somebody in the
head with a sniper rifle you die
normally how you do in this one if it's
a higher level you know but that's the
way an RPG works that's what the game
mechanics are and that's fine I mean
that's literally the way game the game
goes you're gonna have higher na it's
it's an RPG so you are gonna have higher
health pools higher damage weapons and
those types of things for my feel for
Washington DC I liked it it was it was
different than New York and nothing
against New York it was its own thing
but you definitely got the you had the
the very grid streets and everything it
was still you know a decent grid to a
point but you had some more openings you
had the White House lawn that you came
up when you did the opening of the beta
which was felt really cool I gotta be
honest I actually walked in the Oval
Office and I was like damn like those
things were cool to feel for like that
first time the way you the strongholds
were they strongholds I can't I keep
calling that from anthem but I was like
I forget the
outside base areas that you'd go like
help out to build up yeah oh you go by
the settlements settlements yeah sorry
wrong word see I told Jones the wrong
word like the settlements were cool
because you have these things I hear you
eventually will like build up a roof on
top of and you like have the evolution
of these other areas it will help you
kind of unlock things so I mean they've
got a lot of systems in there too which
is cool I mean as you said the guns will
feel some of mine felt like trash mm-hmm
but they're early their beta got they're
like low level guns I took me a little
while to even get a scope so I could
start hitting some people so some of
that stuff takes a little while it still
feels like a sniper rifle especially if
you're gonna play any but you like
playing aggressive is definitely gonna
take a build for it early on you still
gonna stay in cover gotta have a sniper
rifle for some shots have something for
those guys who run up close I don't know
I was like for me and this is what a lot
of people have felt if you like division
one you're gonna like this one
if Division one either you got tired of
it or you were looking for something new
this is not it I mean Division 2 is
Division one
evolved they took a lot of things they
learn they took a lot of the systems
some are normalized the menus kind of
seem real Jinky I don't know and that's
one of those things like whether it's
good better otherwise but on PC I felt
like there were so many clicks I had to
double-click things in my menu I'm like
that should be singles only and so there
were no no believe me I was like and
there's some stuff like they had just
did one piece of it then there's more
but it's like not still not perfect
either so it's like you I I was like
shadow we've been like Bungie's destiny
UI has been work in progress before it
came out but I mean they managed to nail
something pretty well at least in that
that's been pretty good so far as for
healing for me that's a different animal
now I will definitely say the having to
stay in cover more it's definitely a lot
more tactical and that's what they
wanted so I mean they absolutely nailed
the fact that if you're out of cover
you're in trouble but I will definitely
say there are times when I tried to get
up and like start sprinting or get into
sprinting or trying to move like it felt
a little
or lumbering it felt like the Colossus
would basically an anthem lake the
Colossus bid like I did that struggle
with moving in this game at all like oh
I can't blink no I would like mice my
sprinting felt slow trying to get
between cover like sometimes just feel
like I'm starting like step out of mud
real quick like now mine felt my didn't
feel like the vision one felt as I
thought it should blank it was tactical
you had those pieces you could move if I
was going between cover if I wanted to
sprint it felt like it was there in this
one it just everything felt sluggish to
me and I don't know if it was the build
or what but it just felt mine felt off
and again like open beta maybe we'll see
if they get some changes in there or
something like that but mine felt yeah
because it's literally if you like
division ones move it's literally
division ones movement it's just it's
something felt off from either what I
remember what I know it's just been too
long but yeah as like it was it was
different so I don't know but that was
like but I mean some of the stuff
they're doing with like the taking over
of the black tusk like to evolve the
entire world they're giving that like
upgraded world space of like everything
you went through and cleared out and
everything getting taken over there
giving it a lore reason to have you go
back and fight all those missions so as
we said before what is your looter
shooter of choice because you're gonna
be repeating stuff you know what
different ways different things and it's
like what what floats your fancy we're
probably gonna be playing all three of
them I'm sorry I was like I know I was
hard on it right there I really was but
for me as I was like as I got done
playing anthem as you said it felt new
which is like you know can the new new
hotness and then I kind of as Will Smith
says I'm gonna black you got old busted
well this is like it's not old and
busted but it's like it's like Division
one polished up or new hotness and you
get like I'm give Iron Man suits first
division if division doesn't for you
then it's like they took that game they
polished it up they've kind of like
clean some things up they've added lore
they've had evolutions two missions
they've added a ton of stuff in there to
give the people who like division more
now they're figuring stuff like the
underground survival and those are may
things that come in later you know the
free stuff but then you've got
so and then there's different pieces to
they're free and you'll pass it's like
Oh case you get the free stuff but if
you pay early or get this version you'll
get three days before all the free stuff
so it was like everybody's got their
different version whether it's like
anthem with its you know I get the week
early just because I'm not PC but I'm
not really going PvP if you get three
days early access to new content because
you paid for it then that's a little
different too so everybody's got their
different pieces I mean a lot of it is
again I get it
new hotness you know something new and
it feels great you know I get that
aspect all I would say to you and some
guys because clearly we bill which
direction you're leading from what up
from the - I played that's that's my I
feel of fun I'm revision versus Anthony
only reason why I have nothing against
Anthony just mine
my issue comes down to once the newness
wears off and it gets down to a Diablo
end game which is the same strikes the
same strongholds just on grandmaster
difficulty where the mechanics do not
change and it's just bullet sponge how
long am I gonna be playing it that
that's my only concern with the game
whereas with division we have mechanics
and we have raised and in-game content
so that's my thing like once the
narrative is finished and you've got the
cool story and they're doing these
boombastic trailers and that sounds
great
what is gonna keep driving me to keep
doing that cuz you're gonna get to a
point where you're gonna get those bills
right you're gonna get those cool
abilities a shout-out to MTAC she has a
great anthem video right now you know as
far as like what to do right off the bat
and it's like you know again the
stronghold just seems to me like bullet
sponge boss and it's no other mechanics
you know I'm saying it's just I'm
concerned about the long term I really
am I'm gonna turn that once that the
hype of being Iron Man wears off and you
doing that same three strongholds or
whatever it is I I'm hoping these
cataclysms or something cool and
different because I can see this thing
fizzling
if they don't keep content comping
that's I'm you're you're not wrong
like and that's a way of mine too but
also I was like I've said to weep no one
has enough time to play all of this
stuff and for me of one of the reasons
I'm kind of looking forward to anthem in
that way is if I look if I look into
anthem and I play like 40 hours 50 hours
like burn it hard for a month
and then you know Division 2 comes out
it's got the new hotness it's feeling
good it's got the rate up but I got 50
hours out of anthem like I'm good and
ended up I went through the lore and I
got that leg and it makes me step away
from destiny for a little bit maybe I
just do my quick Tuesday thing here here
and there but I'm playing mostly anthem
for like a month and it makes me step
off honestly that's a refresher that I'm
looking forward to even if it isn't
doesn't last forever I knew it I will
get you one day let me tell you what
this is you you a chi basu are on the
same way but I know what's going on here
you guys are making business decisions
and when I leave on that is you gotta
say hey Destiny's first love or whatever
it may be right and you're like I can't
do both for these guys and I get it I
can't do all three of these much less
two of them it's a pain in the butt to
translate fine time to really deep on
any of these like I mean you got destiny
coming with season 2 The Drifter we'll
see how deep that I mean what if destiny
to seize the Drifters like deep what if
they actually have some stuff and
they're you gonna be like stepping back
from the other two you're gonna be like
it's hard to balance all three it's just
there's no question about it so what
what the reason why I say I said what I
said with you a lot so is that if anthem
is just that let's just say worst case
it is just that it's the perfect
distraction game to get away from
destiny and still be able to come back
to it and still be able for both to
co-exist right we're at it comes
division like here that's like another
relationship you gotta get into
and I just want folks to be honest about
some of their reasonings as to why they
are making decisions that they I'm not
saying anthem anthem looks phenomenal
so is this podcast although I am jumping
on we're gonna do this thing that you
know maybe there's no that I'm not
hating on it but I just I realized
what's happening is that Luther shooter
space is very full right now and people
are making business decision I mean you
you gotta figure out where your time
feels important and for me the fun I had
like playing Division to bethe felt like
okay yes I'm back in Division one it's
just in a different place it didn't grab
me the way I jumped off the ledge my
first javelin jump jump fly like it felt
different casting lightning down as a
storm is different than pulling up my 50
Cal that for one is way too zoomed and
is that 50 Cal in that specialization
it's like whoa this is real twitchy and
still like when I pull out the 50 Cal it
was like that's supposed to be like your
ultimate and then all of a sudden I
shoot again and I'm like okay I did some
damage what if I drop like if I pull out
the siege cannon on a colossus and yeah
it has a different feel and it's like do
you like the tactics or do you like the
spaceman you can that's gonna be part of
part of where the fun lines to and
that's different strokes for different
folks that's honestly the point of I
don't hate any of these I'm not trying
to bash any of them it's like my initial
feeling no my initial feeling was anthem
over division if anthem fizzles and
division holds on and those raids are
cool but then again I want to see what
these raids offer because you take a
destiny raid and you have things like
you know of X Timelord
or you have a taken king to fight
against and if I'm fighting with I mean
that's where I wonder how much variety
you can have is there is there going to
be like you know a helicopter airship
that you've got to shoot pieces off of
to try and like you know knock it down
and then have just some armor dude come
out like how do the mechanics work on on
a Division two in-game boss when all we
think so far is basically some dude
armored somebody with a minigun on like
a perch has just kind of a you know a
defender point like it's like what and
we don't have a clue what the mechanics
are but again when you keep it grounded
in reality how far out of that box can
you get any given what you have to say
how far they step or at least how
creative they get and I am quite curious
to see what an eight-person raid to
different team may be working on you
know similar like infiltrating like
honestly this is one thing I would love
from destiny or you know if they ever
add like in more in-game stuff to anthem
it's like I want to see two teams split
up and it's one thing we rarely got in
you know what that's like
split up working on multiple things at
the same time but you can't see each
other you have to talk but you can't see
each other and you're like okay we got
this room we got this room and then you
come together and you've gotta like
bring stuff in or you've got a flank
from both sides be like hey I'm gonna
grab his attention you got your big
sniper ready okay I'm gonna pull him
turn him you guys on the other team
unload on his backside so we can do that
if it's something like that yeah I mean
yeah you're gonna get me in there pretty
damn quick so it's like I'm dead
seriously those are the things if you
make it okay you make the room that are
gonna be like you know cuz d1 incursions
I'm sorry that first would just work
either being like it's all a right it's
an eighteen see the fire rockets all
time and what we're underground in a
room and you're firing explosions one
everyone including the enemies are all
deaf because you're in door explosions
over and over - at some point it's just
not gonna feel good and all that other
stuff so I was like if you give me more
to work through is gonna be a thing but
honestly it's like if you give me more
armored bullet sponges I mean you know
how many heavy armored guys that they
have in d1 in those incursions they had
nothing but heavy spongy spongy guys
like if they release like release like
the army of like five armored guys
you're like Shh okay
so yeah speculate all day we'll just
have a real quick shout out to Sam Arie
fan
thank you brother with the file Alice
Cooper chat what you know today thank
you so yeah we passionate man we love
these looter shooters we get crazy but
you know we gotta had a last word and
he's got over the last word
right now fast like it was it was the
difference in this is still division I
mean it is absolutely division it is a
pure on sequel as a sequel to a game
should be destiny but the page man no no
odds that I never said it's a bad thing
I said if you like division this is a
true buy and buy this is a sequel
keeping things like very true to what it
was
some Aleutians adding more don't like
the terminology you're using that it's
the same because it's not and here's the
reasons why it's not the same they my
god hold on okay you can log into
division 2 and tell me it doesn't feel
like division 1 that's what we're trying
to do it feels like I logged into
division 1 I mean people say on 1.5 but
it's like they're longing it's still
division when you're finish I'll tell
you why it's not the difference is this
ok first of all again you stopped
playing Division 1 after the initial
incursions probably around the same time
I stopped playing right and that we came
to the same determination that um you
know bullet spongy you know really know
mechanically encourages with trash
nobody liked it then they pretty much
made update after update change the way
systems work change put gear systems all
that stuff loot armor systems on armor
sets all that kind of change the way
exotic works change the way things drop
ok cool then survival making mole came
out which I don't know if he played or
not survival mode was excellent
that wasn't it's coming that's what I'm
trying to say you haven't been paying it
you've been so in your anthem bag with
everything that they're saying in here
right now no it's not it's coming and
here's the figure listen shut up when's
the raid coming for anthem exactly at
least a developer are saying these
things are coming that's all I'm trying
to say and with what you call it's one
week after launch anthem we they already
told
you there are no raids they told you
that so and it's what what out what
here's my counter to you after you free
roam all day after you do grandmaster
difficulty then what
that's some trust I'm gonna have six
things I can do I could be in the dark
soul I can do PvP which anthem does not
have you know I'm saying and I can do a
ring this so that's I'm trying to say so
again you may say that's boring but all
I'm just trying to say is right now if
this is a race you guys got the short
term you're new you're hot you're fly
you're doing things that's different but
if this is a marathon I can see this
thing passing this game anthem if anthem
does not keep up content and we still
don't know if the narrative is good you
could show me all the will whatever his
name trailers that's not in the game
that's a movie some do made on the side
that's not in the game let's see what it
is do they have that Bioware feel do
they have those characters that you're
gonna care about that's gonna make you
want to play again so let's let's put
fingers written down characters that I
care about by the way because I didn't I
didn't have any characters I mean I
could name one person in anthem three
missions you talk to one dude it was
nothing interesting about any of them
there was nothing that felt dragon's age
did you play Mass Effect right none of
knows no I can name one character by
name and anthem that's iconic that made
you feel away nobody was the one dude in
the mission you talk to and I can tell
you his name right there before we start
crowning things I never said I'm
crowning anything I've said I have my
reservations about anthem I'm just
saying division two as they feel is
truly like she'll begin chat I think
Division two is if you if you play
Division one and you're like hey this
game isn't for me would you tell someone
to play Division two
probably not if they don't let attack
okay but that's but that's a different
argument I mean that's one thing is like
this is is a very very very good
evolution of division you have the PvP
in there you have the dark zone split up
now I have my issues with the dark zone
but that's just me
you've got you know potential if these
other things do come like survival was
cool like having everybody on the same
playing field all that stuff was I liked
that meant at the underground like the
evolution those were cool like different
ways and they've got the gear sets
coming in pretty quickly believe me I
wish I had gear sets and destiny oh my
god do I wish I do so I mean there are
things about it that I really really
like and trust me like there are things
like they deep dive in the numbers now a
lot of the perks that I've seen had like
a plus and a minus which is kind of
weird yeah does get to be like plus and
plus if you get to in-game a Division
one you start they can go down a road of
Opie builds that are unkillable again
you stop playing I know I did I'm not
saying I didn't talk with that because
all those things that what creative for
balance have been implemented that's all
I'm saying bro it's just not for you you
wanna be iron man I get it
iron man is cool I get it and a lot of
people want to be iron man all I'm
saying is let's revisit this three
months down the road six months yeah and
let's see what happens I just feel more
confident with the bland roaring same
game that actually has an in-game and
actually has things to come back to then
something that I'm unsure of that maybe
it's a one-and-done kind of a situation
that's all you so I guess this is the
question so if it does play play out
like you're speculating you prefer a I
mean you literally just set a bland
boring in-game about using your words
I'm just saying you said it's uh bland
boring in-game versus a flash in the pan
I'm not I'm not gonna say bland boring
in-game because one reason you just said
it Russians were we got raids now I
don't know what raids are and then
question I hope they are good I really
do me too I hope they're great - I just
know eight players even Destiny's not
doing eight so I know what that feels
like how how is that going I will say
this if you guys are curious about
endgame aspect with division
please watch Eric's video he's sitting
down with ball for the devs I'll try to
get the link to it and he questioned him
not only did he say the dev say the
rates are going to be mechanic heavy
which surprised me I was like mechanics
really did he said raids uh plural so
that really got me excited because to be
honest I thought this would just be some
flashing plan thing they try and it's
just like okay we did it we said we did
it for a buzzword marketing thing they
are really going at to see the
difference between Ubisoft and Bungie is
they actually seem like they've learned
from their mistakes nothing wrong they
have continued to evolve I'm not gonna
bet against someone who feels like
that's learned because when division one
is faulty as it was it took the Destiny
community away when it launched I
remember those days man so we'll see and
I'm not wishing anything bad or and and
we go and play it is anything I'm just
wanna I just want to see long-term
that's all I want to see I just want to
see what else is there is am I gonna
burn out that's my only concern I mean I
like the I will say like what they have
learned is really good because d1 you
got to the end like hey go to the dark
so get all this stuff I absolutely hated
the dark zone because you would just get
trolled so that got really really really
really old the fact that you have the
world of all of you know the black tusk
people to fight you have potentially
like those contracts that you found her
the bounties I found some dude in the
end game mission I wandered around after
I popped out and I found like some guy
who was gonna give me like a contractor
I couldn't do it but it was like there
was a dude sitting in a corner having
this like secret like like it was like a
drug bust gone wrong but I was actually
like what did you see that guy did you
find him where you know what I'm talking
about I I didn't account of what I've
seen it yeah okay yeah so I was like I
ran into that guy
like oh this is gonna be something else
to go fight so if there are things and
honestly the way like as myself when I
went through that in-game mission now
grain and that was a pretty stout build
obviously but it did feel doable
it didn't feel ridiculous the way if I
tried to solo what were they called
before in d1 you know when they took the
missions to like ultra hard you know
what I'm talking about you told my team
it was division 1 division 1 it was like
you'd go back in and you'd crank it up
and if like I want to try and do that
thing solo it was so hard it was stupid
like if they have the difficulty to a
point where it's like actually doable
take some time to get there and actually
feels like stuff I can solo and I don't
have to go do to the dark zone by myself
but there's still plenty of stuff to do
and that's the thing this is coming from
a solo player tough it has a solo player
depending on the matchmaking which
seemed pretty smooth even though I
didn't do it I heard it was pretty solid
if those are gonna be options in there
then I can go put another 1500 hours in
division and see where I end up and I'm
gonna be cool with that too so for me
it's like it's just is the drive for me
to go into division because it's it is
the realism how did everything feel like
if some of the tweaks are like you know
and everything's gonna have a beta build
which is gonna be from a while ago same
thing as anthem was it perfect no
there's a patch today but it's like if I
jump into division and I can go throw
some hours into that and that gives me
again during this season of The Drifter
which is gonna be this evolution of
gambit which may not last that long this
may be a perfect time that actually I
can't play both of them so I have my
fingers crossed that both of these are
cool they're gonna be different animals
completely one is gonna be that and
we'll see what the evolution is the
other is alert a game of a a sequel of a
long supported game that has some cool
evolutions that I'm hoping keep my
interest absolutely that's and that's my
hope so we'll see I mean like I said
it's not for everybody I'm not gonna
fool myself into thinking there's gonna
be people like a dizzy who's in the chat
who the me business just needed a dizzy
just just me represents a subset of
gamers that
you know they're not trying to do any
type of cover based you know tactical
con that's just not their thing you know
I'm saying just the same thing like you
said I'm full aware that there's people
that's like hey at the end of the day is
just guys what armor it's not me I want
space magic you know there's guys like
Death Grips was at lunch I was like yo
I'm you know after a while you get tired
of that
anything want that you know change of
pace kind of thing and it's gonna come
down to what you love first right the
style of game you love first a style of
looter shooter you like first and then
the execution of said who the shooters
or that you know like I said cuz I'll
tell you right now anthem keeps bringing
it right and and then I don't even care
if they don't I'll tell you this this is
where anthem will steal me away from the
vision say these are words I haven't
heard before right no it's not but I'll
give you the blueprint what they gotta
do I'm gonna play it I'm gonna love it
but I'm just saying to keep me there
right what they're gonna have to do is
say okay this is like kind of what Mass
Effect you should do it like every DLC
it would be a very heavy intense
narrative driven thing well I want to
know what happens to the freelancers I
want to know what's going on and it's so
story driven and it's hot and then the
other thing that they could gotta do
even if they're not gonna do Ray's right
they got a do stronghold
well I'm fighting some epic Oryx looking
kind of thing right and you know you
gotta fly up
you used your verticality use the things
that no one else can do not even Stinney
they've got a scope they've got a
foundation that is so new that is so
cool that they can make something epic
if they ever need to me can you fight
man could you could you imagine I'll do
like Joe was playing strong mission
before like I mean that spiders yeah
like I mean it's not bigger than me
obviously it's big squishy but like take
that thing and crank it up by I don't
know 10x and like how do when you're
going through the stronghold you're in
the second area where you're picking up
all the little nub can't remember the
name little glowy things you're getting
the 12 on that side
imagine a dude lake you know five
designs of spiders walking around in an
area like yeah that's the type of stuff
boy if B could you imagine like an Oryx
Ora arm sob what's the Riven in in
anthems world yeah Riven actually fully
exposed and it's over then it if
everybody needs to pack their Luther
shooter and go home that's what I know
the potential it is gay I don't want to
come across as hey trust me I just need
to see it and give me that story give me
that good stuff man I will betray
division so fast
I know as Kate said the kitchen in the
bushes what all right bye or you heard
it if you ever listen to this you know
what it takes to get division in the
bushes you've got your answer
they took it I could grab eight of my
friends a division maybe if it's any bit
cooler it's 44 and they split us
something it's like hey you guys do this
and you break that segment up and you
man it could be special we'll see I mean
it's all gonna come down to the
execution of both games I was like I
think the potential of anthem as you're
saying if they can really ever deep dive
into something up that scale none of
these other games I mean destiny can do
it's space magic pieces but like it
can't touch it because anthem can get
that scale as you're saying now the
other piece about it as well as you're
saying hey there's PvP involved we still
have the piece of destiny coming back if
things have to be PvP balanced if you go
into that in that end game dark zone the
occupied one word everything's on the
playing field you can't have anything
broken anthem keep anthem King keep
throne broken stuff at you because all
you're gonna do is fight crazier stuff
so it's like there are some benefits of
being PvE only and that's one thing that
we'll have to see how that plays out too
is if it's worth it absolutely don't
forget the fact that remnants to its
dark sorrow technique PvE versus PvE and
PvP and then this standard PvP only did
you do Stan
at PvP only with the arm the the but
I've got the name of the term it's kind
of like deathmatch and then they have
the other one yeah I didn't quite get
the end of that one I'm gonna try it on
the open beta yeah so just wait you'll
fight Metal Gear de visite - yeah but
see that's what I was gonna save that I
wasn't even gonna go at him with that
I'm gonna say cuz even hate imma save
that cuz he have Metal Gear yeah just a
mech but I was like like okay so what am
I gonna do - like a mech warrior telling
you listen that black tusk faction is
doing and it's you they Trojan horsing
something that you guys don't even
realize which is the non human element
type you know say it's gonna be these
robot type things
no angle robot dogs and you can get
creepy you can get creepy we'll see
we'll see if we got terminators and
robot I'm good robot dogs and giant
space dragons we're just gonna be
playing all the games we've both been
having been fighting for these games oh
yeah
it's it's been fun I mean that's kind of
the thing you guys see our passion it's
like Destiny's there we've been in this
thing for five years we're gonna stick
with it we're gonna see what happens but
our feelings are that they're playing
their cards pretty right this season The
Drifter and evolution of gambit is not
gonna be this like you know there's
probably gonna be less to it than armory
honestly I'm is my hunch the black
armory probably had more than season The
Drifter is my feeling they're saving
some for it acted to get some height
back up or at least they had to stick to
that plan and then main they on may on
estai just have to drop the ball come
III that there may not be that much more
we'll see but we've got two games
different feels both potentially a lot
of fun some love some hate going both
directions and that's okay it's honestly
just to see where the things settle and
honestly if you have the flash on the
pain and anthem have a good time and
then you jump into division and you're
grinding up every little gear bit thing
you can well guess what you got to have
fun as a gamer and it's a hell of a time
to be a gamer great time listen that's
why I love that we actually be changed
on name to last word because um is all
shout out vagabond oh thank you bro that
means a lot thank you for that comment
you got your game easy yeah because at
the end of the day I like that we
changed it because we're in a space now
where it's not just destiny right we're
in this space but we got these great
games you know all at one time
and we got had a last word on these
things man we got it we got to talk
about it does that we can't just
pigeonhole ourselves because there's
some really cool ideas out there content
and again at the end of the day
competition is good
it pushes it's gonna push Bungie it's
gonna push massive it's gonna push
Bioware you know I mean like this is
what you want and ultimately it's gonna
make these games better and you know you
know so maybe one of them doesn't
survive we'll see you know saying but at
the end of the day they're gonna go hard
to try all three them to retain their
communities it's a good time man but
let's get him on society I kept the man
all right kept a sick man arguing I
apologize I kept this very fighting to
today this man is sick man we gotta get
him out here he's got videos to do and
rest after all right guys it's been a
hell of a lot of fun this morning chaps
have both been on fire
shout out to vagabond Oh said Fred dizzy
just been mean up here this morning I'm
a fan right it's been it's been great
all you guys ravager Death Grips
everybody so I'm gonna fire yeah I know
all you guys are there death all Michael
so you guys have all been amazing this
morning thank you guys very much on me
the voice will hold on to what it can
feel like I'm just clear my throat
occasionally it's doing alright
but yeah anthem is we gonna be jumping
in so I'll be streaming some of it
potentially so if you guys don't want
any spoilers don't watch it's up to you
I'll put a spoiler warning on there but
outside of that I'm gonna be jumping
into the campaign and yeah that's that's
pretty much all my god it's Aventis
everywhere you guys know I'm still gonna
do my destiny stuff I don't even know if
I'm gonna take the time to do serve
right now it comes out an hour so we'll
see but yeah lots of stuff going on it's
been awesome and it's all I got
hey bon says everywhere YouTube twitch
and twitter find me you know where to
find me absolutely Mashhadi for coming
through it still
last word today really was fun man I
know the man is sick and he definitely
still can't and we had a fan I think
what am i bad
what about brilliant we're pretty good
pretty good going out up there good this
is good at the end of day like I said
thanks for doing it but um yeah man you
know do me at Lord kognito
on Twitter and I'm on YouTube the iron
law podcast return Sunday at 1 p.m.
Eastern every Sunday is the Lord's Day
we will have bloody knuckles from the
smash podcast we'll be talking gaming
we'll be talking little film little
comic movie a little anime um but
primarily gaming a lot of what's going
on in the industry right now crackdown 3
yeah the Nintendo Direct will be
discussed obviously we will touch a
little bit of anthem that'll be released
as well because I that's a Tetris 99 by
the way all right agreement oh yeah
battle royale Tetris is free for free so
make sure you go they still dropped a
lot of stuff man and this is a good time
and like I said everyone please get on
that anthem if you're in our origin
access or EA access touch it up you know
we're gonna break this thing down when
we return next week and again thanks for
my brother he boxes are coming through
man no he was sick and I'm so glad that
was able to do this show there was a lot
of fun but that's all I got me yeah so
to everyone out there enjoy your weekend
whatever it holds mines gonna be a lot
of the division so I will see you all
and yeah we have a good one peace see